hello ho ho everyone and welcome to a
very nice game that was played in 1848
in berlin germany but it's actually
known more today as an opening trap
rather than a game between carl might
and daniel horowitz and uh
i've used this many many a time in
bullet in blitz
i've even seen i haven't used it myself
but i've seen it used in
classical chess uh when we were playing
uh our club against um
another club in the league i've seen my
teammate was playing this and i couldn't
believe it actually happened over the
board in a classical game
but something you can use and usually on
christmas i will show you
either a puzzle or something like that
this year i decided to do
this game which is basically a puzzle
because it's only like six moves that
are
important and it also features the
queen's gambit and that's like the most
popular thing today
uh so let's uh let's see what's
happening here so might with
the white pieces opens with that's not a
d4
d4 uh we have d5c for
uh the queen's gambit is on the board
and now e6 we have knight to c3
knight to f6 and bishop to g5 and this
is a
perfectly normal setup of the queen's
gambit declined and here
black will play knight beat to d7 and
here you are playing black
and you you kind of want to trick your
opponent into capturing on d5 because
now the queen is no longer guarding the
d5 square
so here your opponent will capture on d5
c captures uh you're gonna recapture
e captures on d5 and now your opponent
should play something like e3 knight f3
basically just continue development
and so on however uh you can also see
that the d5 pawn is actually free
because the knight is pinned the knight
cannot capture because black
loses the queen and sometimes not often
but sometimes
white will actually capture the spawn
and now white is completely lost so
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for black
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the knight can actually move uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
knight captures on d5 black gives up the
queen
but only temporarily here bishop
captures the queen is played because
you're now down a piece you have to
recapture
bishop captures queen and now you finish
the game with
bishop to be for check and now white
realizes that uh that was not a free
pawn and most definitely not
because now the king has nowhere to go
we reach the position from the thumbnail
and only move for white uh is queen to
d2 you have to block check
and now you don't even have to capture
right away you can just capture the
bishop and
whatever white plays you're just going
to end up this whole variation being up
a piece
so let's say rook d1 or e3 doesn't
really matter
you can just capture the queen or or
whatever
or even if queen captures bishop you
just capture the queen
my point is white always loses the queen
and now if you count the pieces
you can see that black has two rooks
white has two rooks black has a bishop
white has a bishop
but black has two knights whereas white
only has one night so black is up a
piece
and of course you are now uh well more
more than able to to win this game
easily
so uh we're gonna show it once again uh
just because it's uh super super simple
d4d5 c4 so the queen's gambit knight f6
knight
sorry uh e6 first
let's go with that knight c3 knight f6
and now uh
bishop to g5 so probably a position you
will most likely reach most of the times
knight beat to d7 and now of course
captures captures
and the deadly characters and now you
can just give up the queen
uh black has to capture and bishop to be
for check and
white probably resigns here but if they
continue you're up a piece so
it doesn't really matter you can play it
any way you like you can capture the
queen first then capture the bishop
everything works uh but yeah that's uh
the
the game i hope you guys enjoyed it i
was very happy when i saw this
the first time and i was always trying
to use it against my opponents and
uh if if such a position arises if
in lower elo uh then uh you you will
probably
win the game if white tries this against
you
uh so yeah that's uh that's the game i
already said it was a very short one
i do hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank uh thomas de genaro
uh alexandra coburn thomas kenworthy
benson farm and steven lowen for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day